[Music]
in January as inter Miami arrived in El
Salvador for its first preseason match
of 2024 hundreds of cheering fans
greeted the team's Convoy of pink buses
jostling past one another just to catch
a glimpse of arguably the most famous
athlete on the planet lonel Messi such
an impassioned welcome in a foreign
country would have been unimaginable 8
months ago when inter Miami one of the
more recent editions to Major League
Soccer was a last place club with little
Global recognition Beyond its minority
co-owner David Beckham but all that
changed in June when Messi announced
that South Florida would become his next
soccer home forever altering the
franchise's
trajectory Forbes estimates inter Miami
is now mls's second most valuable
franchise at $103 billion and they're
not the only ones reaping the benefits
of Messi Mania clubs lucky enough to
host games against Miami in 2023 scored
massive gate Revenue increases including
the New York Red Bulls Nashville SC and
the Chicago Fire which Drew over 62,000
fans to Soldier Field for a game in
which Messi never actually played those
bumps additional games from the
inaugural leagues Cup Tournament and a
move by MLS to decrease the ticket
Revenue it collects from teams helped
power a 20% increase in average revenue
across the league to $66 million in
2023 also bolstering the league are the
rising valuations across other American
Sports for ultra high n worth
individuals with dreams of owning a
sports team MLS remains a cost friendly
option Forbes now estimates the average
MLS Club is worth $658 million up 14%
from a year ago here are Major League
Soccer top five most valuable clubs for
2024 at number five is New York City FC
worth an estimated $850 million the club
is majority owned by City football group
the parent company of English Premier
League Powerhouse house Manchester City
but Yankee Global Enterprises which is
controlled by the steinner family has a
piece as well nycfc currently splits
time between Yankee Stadium and City
Field as its home venue but plans to
move into a new soccer specific stadium
in Queens in
2027 Atlanta United ranks number four
worth an estimated $900 million the club
which is owned by Home Depot co-founder
and Atlanta Falcons owner Arthur Blank
had an early playoff exit last season
but remains one of the best moneyy
makers in the sport Atlanta's $95
million in 2023 revenues is tied for
third in the league with the LA
Galaxy speaking of the LA Galaxy Philip
an shoots his franchise ranks number
three with an estimated $950 million the
Galaxy are one of the 10 original MLS
franchises and the club has a rich
history that features stars like David
Beckham Landon Donovan and zlan
Ibrahimovic in the past few years the
Galaxy have become preseason host for
several clubs around the league as part
of the Coachella Valley
Invitational inter Miami is now the
second most valuable MLS team worth an
estimated $1.03 billion after a 72% bump
from a year ago the franchise is the
second in league history to achieve a
billion dollar valuation following in
the CLE footsteps of
lafc a month after his arrival Messi LED
inter Miami to its first ever trophy at
the inaugural leagues cup with a
dramatic penalty shootout Victory off
the field the eight-time balandor winner
supercharged the team's business
operations with Revenue more than
doubling to18 million in 2023 from $56
million in
2022 however Messi's presence on the
roster isn't solely responsible for
inter Miami's $430 million value
increase year-over-year the club has
shrewdly capitalized on its meast star's
commercial potential starting even
before he arrived and the First full
season with in the United States offers
even more upside including increased
Stadium attendance and higher average
ticket
prices and at number one for the second
consecutive year is lafc at an estimated
$1.2 billion the club turned a $9
million operating profit on a leag high
140 million in revenue for 2023 it also
added a 10-year $100 million Stadium
naming rights pack with bimo prior to
last season and in July through an MLs
single game record
82,0 fans to the Rose Bol for its
rivalry match with the LA Galaxy lafc
pads its bottom line with a suite of
non-mls businesses including concerts
and other events bimo Stadium sold more
than 1.3 million tickets in 2023 and
postar ranked the venue number five on
its year-end top 100 stadiums list with
a gross of $19 million despite a
capacity of only
22,000 lafc has also dabbled in building
its own network of soccer teams adding a
90% stake in Switzerland's grasshopper
Club
[Music]
Zurich